zeitreisen sind mathematisch möglich an
der university of queensland wurde jetzt
errechnet dass all die verwicklungen aus
dem film zurück in die zukunft nicht
passieren werden das universum würde sie
kalibrieren wie bitte klicks um
science-fiction gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und vergesslich den
podcast klicks und wird immer beliebter
als podcast und man kann geht es um dann
hören wann und wo man will
wenn man gerade kein video gucken kann
also weiter 30 abonnieren und natürlich
hören
die links sind hier unter oder in der
video beschreibung oder im ersten
kommentar
eine ganze filmreihe lebt von diesem
wissenschaftlichen problem der
zeitreisen dem großvater paradoxon wenn
ich in die vergangenheit reisen und mein
großvater töte werde ich nicht geboren
und kann auch mein großvater nicht
umbringen in sorge in die zukunft reist
marty mcfly in die vergangenheit dort
verliebt sich seine zukünftige mutter in
ihn und nicht in seinem vater er würde
nicht geboren werden hier endet das
paradoxon in teil eins denn wenn er
nicht geboren werden würde dann könnte
sich seine mutter auch nicht in ihn
verlieben sie würde seinen vater
heiraten er könnte doch geboren werden
und seine mutter könnte sich wiederum in
ihn verlieben und so weiter und so fort
naja vielleicht würden wir dadurch das
ende des universums herbeiführen oder
und das ist der punkt der neuen studie
es würde sicher weg kalibrieren aus
stephen hawking hat sich mit dem problem
der zeitreisen beschäftigt sie von
hawking gehört nicht nur zu den
renommiertesten wissenschaftlern
weltweit er war auch ein großer visionär
und hat auch durchaus kontroversen
thesen vertreten und er hat auch
verrückte experimente gemacht eines
davon betrifft zeitreisen denn hawking
schloss zumindest die möglichkeit nicht
aus das ist zeitreisen geben könnte und
er hatte gute grund dafür denn die
relativitätstheorie lässt zeitreisen zu
der mathematiker kurt gödel entdeckte
1949 das albert einsteins feld
gleichungen geschlossene zeit artige
kurven zulässt oder schleifen und die
könnten da entstehen wo die raumzeit
extrem gekrümmt wird zb in einem
rotierenden schwarzen loch und die
meisten schwarzen löcher rotieren und
das mit
einer atemberaubenden geschwindigkeit
oder in einem bohrloch stephen hawking
ist sich sicher in der zukunft werden
wir in die zukunft reisen können und das
ist eigentlich nichts besonderes denn
wenn man sich mit der speziellen
relativitätstheorie beschäftigt nicht
bewegt sich immer mit derselben
geschwindigkeit fort mit der
unabänderlichen geschwindigkeit von 299
millionen 792 1458 meter pro sekunde das
sind so rund eine milliarde kilometer
pro stunde
und wenn es mit materie interagiert wird
es gestoppt aber bewegte sich fort ist
diese geschwindigkeit in stein gemeißelt
da die lichtgeschwindigkeit aber
unabänderlich ist muss ich alles andere
darum verändern raum und zeit werden
gekrümmt bei hohen geschwindigkeiten
führt das zu einem langsamen verlauf der
zeit das heißt im umkehrschluss
außerhalb zum beispiel eines
raumschiffes dass ich mit annähernd
lichtgeschwindigkeit vorweg verläuft die
zeit viel schneller und das kann zum
beispiel heißen dass an bord eines
schnell fliegenden raumschiffes ein jahr
vergeht während auf der erde zehn jahre
vergehen
auf diese weise könnten wir also in
zukunft in die zukunft fliegen es geht
sogar mit geringen geschwindigkeiten die
die beiden wissenschaftler josef häfele
und richard keating haben das übrigens
in ihrem berühmten havel keating es 471
gemacht sie flogen mit atomuhren an bord
eines flugzeuges um die erde danach
verglichen sie die zeit der hohen
exakten atomuhren an bord mit atomuhren
am boden und tatsächlich waren sie in
die zukunft gereist ihre uhren gingen
nach die zeit an bord war langsamer
vergangen die erste offizielle zeitreise
in die zukunft aber geht es auch zurück
theoretisch könnten geschlossene zeit
artige schleifen genau das ermöglichen
doch es gibt ein problem
ein wichtiges prinzip der physik ursache
und wirkung würden damit auf den kopf
gestellt denn die ursache liegt demnach
immer in der vergangenheit und die
wirkung der zukunft deshalb wagte
hawking ein spannendes experiment er
veranstaltete eine party schickten die
einladung erst nach der partie auf
besonders haltbarem papier ab das würde
also jahrtausende überdauern dieses
papier nachfahren von uns hätten die
einladung eigentlich finden müssen doch
auf der party erschien kein einziger
gast zumindest in diesem experiment
konnte er also ursache verschicken der
einladung in die zukunft und wirkung
partygäste in der vergangenheit
umkehren es spricht also einiges dafür
dass zeitreisen in die vergangenheit
nicht gibt wir hätten solche
zeitreisende schon längst aufspielen
müssen aber es gibt ja eine quelle die
viel effizienter in der lage ist
zeitreisende aufzuspüren das internet
und da hat sich ein forschungsteam daran
gemacht dass nach zeitreisenden zu
durchsuchen sie forschen einfach auf
twitter nach ob es jeweils einen
einzigen tipp gibt der das erscheinen
des kometen iso und 2012 voraus sagt
oder die wahl von hoche bergoglio zum
papst franziskus das ergebnis auf ganz
twitter gibt es keinen einzigen täter
ein solches ereignis voraus sagt es
sieht also schwer danach aus als das
höchstwahrscheinlich nie zeitreisen in
die vergangenheit möglich werden es ist
also wahrscheinlich so dass es im
bereich der quantenphysik bewegungen in
der umgekehrten zeit richtung geben
könnte aber für uns menschen das nie
realität wird trotzdem bringen die
geschlossenen zeit artigen kurven oder
schleifen oder zeit schleifen physiker
und physikerinnen weltweit um den
verstand denn sie sind eigentlich
unvermeidbar sie existieren demnach und
eine schlaue lösung um das großvater
paradoxon zu vermeiden ist noch niemand
eingefallen bisher beziehungsweise der
russische physiker ego dimitrijevic
novikov vermutete einfach ein verbot
aber vielleicht haben die walking und
die anderen auch einen entscheidenden
fehler gemacht einen denkfehler
denn zwei mathematiker und jetzt kommt
es ja meint ober und fabio costa von der
university of queensland haben dass
großvater paradoxon jetzt mathematisch
gelöst und was sie sagen haut einen
schier vom hocker wenn multiple lokale
region in gegenwart einer zeitschleife
miteinander kommunizieren gibt es eine
reihe von szenarien die dem akteur alle
handlungsfreiheit geben ohne das
logische inkonsistenzen wie das
großvater paradoxen auftreten nur moment
der kann also alles machen was er will
und nichts passiert kein großvater
paradoxon gar nichts die lösung das
universum kalibriert sich neues würde
also die konsequenzen aus dem tod des
großvaters ziehen und alles rund um das
ereignis so kalibrieren dass sich doch
in zukunft exakt mit dem passenden gehen
geboren werden wird
die bandbreite der mathematischen
prozesse die wir entdeckt haben zeigen
dass zeitreisen mit einem freien willen
in unserem universum möglich sind ohne
paradoxon die mathematik dafür ist
stimmig das sagt gehrmann tober erklärt
das phänomen anhand der komik 19 panini
man könnte ja in die vergangenheit
reisen um die infektion von patient null
zu verhindern
im beispiel mit dem patienten 0 der
korona pandemie bedeutet das dass sie
versuchen können den patienten vor der
infektion zu bewahren aber indem sie
dies tun werden sie selbst angesteckt
und nun ihrerseits patient null oder
aber ihre handlung bewirkt die infektion
von jemand anderem das bedeutet die
pandemie würde beginnen egal was sie tun
und beim großvater paradoxon hat der
dann vielleicht vorher samen gespendet
oder einen zwillingsbruder oder oder
oder egal was passiert die beiden
mathematiker konnten zumindest
mathematisch nachweisen dass nichts
passiert jedenfalls nichts was den
zeitstrahl so verändert dass etwas
unmögliches geschieht und vielleicht ist
das genau der denkfehler wenn man zu
einer party in die vergangenheit eine
damit ursache und wirkung nicht
vertauscht werden
re kalibriert sich das universum neu im
fall der einladung verschwinden sie
einfach alle oder bei den vorständen die
nach den tweets aus der zukunft gesucht
haben können diese zwar geschrieben
werden aber gelangen nie an die
öffentlichkeit zum beispiel durch einen
technischen fehler
das universum hätte sich re kalibriert
sprich selbst wenn unsere nachfahren
lustig zurück in die heutige zeit reisen
würden wir könnten es gar nicht bemerken
weil das universum alles um diese reisen
re kalibrieren würde alles was die
zukunft verändern würde würde korrigiert
werden also auch ein wissen über
zeitreisen die stattgefunden haben
könnten wir nie erlangen das universum
würde das durch re kalibrieren
verhindern und jeder und jede die es
noch nicht getan hat sollte sich jetzt
auch marie kalibrieren und zwar im
podcast zu abonnieren die links spotify
und apple sind auch in der video
beschreibung und im angeboten kommentar
also anklicken anhören und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran